jetzt hat man es schwarz auf weiß viele
maßnahmen hatten kaum wirkung es ist die
korona klatsche für das team vorsicht
der expertenrat der bundesregierung der
rechnet jetzt mit den pandemie regeln ab
lange wartete politik und öffentlichkeit
auf die evolution der korona maßnahmen
durch das 18 köpfige expertengremium ja
die experten sollten klären wie wirksam
die maßnahmen gegen die pandemie waren
damit bund und länder im kommenden
herbst alte fehler nicht wiederholen ja
um 12 uhr soll das papier es hat 165
seiten dann öffentlich vorgestellt
werden und wir von bild wir wissen jetzt
schon was drin steht ja es gibt richtig
krach im expertenrat wäre vor allem ein
schneller blick auf die aktuellen zahlen
damit wir die auch im blick haben nach
bundesland gibt es nämlich große
unterschiede ja schauen wir hier in
baden württemberg haben 60,5 prozent der
einwohner die dritte impfung in bayern
sind es
58,5 prozent und in berlin 62,6 prozent
in den ostdeutschen bundesländern ist
die quote also deutlich niedriger in
sachsen zum beispiel
49,5 prozent in thüringen
51,5 prozent ist also der impf
fortschritt aufgeschlüsselt nach
bundesland ja und das ist interessant
obwohl im osten weniger menschen geimpft
sind ist die inzidenz hier niedriger man
sieht es hier ganz deutlich an dieser
karte je dunkler die farbe desto höher
also die incident und wir sprechen jetzt
mit dem virologen und epidemiologen
klaus stört er auch im expertenrat der
bundesregierung setzt also in diesem
gremium dass diese maßnahmen heute
vorstellt das ist doch wirklich der
wahnsinn hallo herr stöhr dass diese
maßnahmen anscheinend ja wirklich kaum
bis gar keine wirkung hatten bedeutet
das jetzt eigentlich im umkehrschluss
dass wir nie wieder ein lockdown erleben
werden dass es nie wieder eine massen
pflicht geben wird das nie wieder jemand
fragt 2g 3g
also ich will den der pressekonferenz
war es ja nicht vorwegnehmen inhaltlich
wurden tatsächlich alle maßnahmen die
relevant für die sachverständigen waren
auch evaluiert inwieweit hier auch ganz
konkrete schlussfolgerungen abgeleitet
werden können für den herbst das mussten
an die politik für dich entscheiden
also wir müssen wir mal abwarten bis die
konkurrenten an
das wären wir natürlich machen
übertragen wir hier dann auch live sehen
uns alle details an aber es ist ja schon
etwas durchgesickert haben wir ja auch
hier gerade andere angesprochen es ist
ja jetzt schon völlig klar dass viele
maßnahmen einfach nichts gebracht haben
und das ist einfach schon während der
ganzen partie sozusagen zwei lager gab
intim vorsicht die die maßnahmen immer
weiter eher verstärken wollten um so
weitere infektions ausbrüche zu
verhindern und das andere team das
gesagt hat das müssen wir aber auch
irgendwie mit der lebensrealität
vereinbart ich denke da beispielsweise
an die schulschließungen die wir dort
hatten mit folgen für so viele kinder
wie gespalten ist da jetzt dieser graben
und was bedeutet das jetzt für uns alle
im herbst es geht ja jetzt schon die
zahlen wir bemerken dass nach oben ich
sehe das bei schulen bei kita jetzt auch
bei mir im umfeld wohin gehen wir dahin
steuern werde im herbst die also die
datenlage hat sich ja dadurch dass die
sachverständigen kommission getagt hat
nicht verändert waren ja auch schon vor
dem oder vorlage des berichtes zum
beispiel klar zumindest auf meinem
blickwinkel vieler seiner kollegen dass
schulschließungen an nicht den beitrag
geliefert haben und konnte die man nicht
erwartet da die daten waren ja schon
2020 1 waren relativ klar dass die
ausbrüche in den schulen sehr seltenen
nur 18 prozent derjenigen die da in
schulen auch krank wurden und positiv
gesessen haben dass videos aus
weitergegeben also es gab dann auch
weniger effekte in den klassen was wie
erwachsenen häufiger die infektion in
die schulen getragen haben als umgekehrt
dass die infektions richtung insgesamt
von eltern kindern also erwachsenen
kindern gegangen gute daten und england
finden die gezeigt haben dass die kinder
weniger an infekt bei uns geschehen
beteiligten als die erwachsenen das hat
man aber konnte könnt negiert in der
vergangenheit ich weiß nicht ob ihre
expertenbericht jetzt einen unterschied
dann macht denn die daten lagen ja auch
schon vorher auf dem tisch
ist die schulschließung ja nicht die
einzige maßnahme wo man dann
offensichtlich auch die informationslage
außer acht gelassen hat gute
publikationen zur wirksamkeit von lok
das kann bis dato keine daten die
belegen
die wirksamkeit gene und kontakt
nachverfolgt die
wirtschaftskommission bereits im januar
letzten jahres angemahnt da müssen das
forschungskonzept der bundesregierung um
die primären priorisierten fragen
epidemiologischen klinischen und public
health fragen zu klären und dann auch
studienergebnisse dazu erreichen die man
geld rein gibt das forschungskonzept
registriert er bis heute nicht das hat
es lange gedauert bevor die
bundesregierung angefangen hat jetzt
nicht zu überlegen wie man die auf den
herbst vorbereitet durch das erkennen
der im unglück und hat man durch viel
druck und mit auf dem letzten tipp die
gelder locker gemacht wird dass jetzt
diese serologischen studien beginnen
können also ist ein komplexes geschehen
man darf nicht vergessen es wurde
natürlich nicht alles falsch gemacht und
immer gesagt keine der maßnahmen
funktioniert das stimmt natürlich auch
nicht die impfung war der
puffer für die erstinfektion es ist
überhaupt keine frage wenn wenn man eine
andere tandem ihrer vergangenheit
gesehen hat oder verstanden hat die
hätten alles getan um eine neben stiften
burg damit unternehmen stoff wieder
jetzt zur verfügung steht die meisten
jedenfalls mit nur einer hohen
wirksamkeit und schwere verläufe zu
verhindern den hatte man auch nicht
erwarten können und dass es neben so
kommen gibt das muss man jetzt aber
genauer untersuchen denn der keinen
impfstoff ich habe doch keine
medikamente überhaupt vom
nebenwirkungsfrei also hier muss man auf
die ballons waren zwischen den dingen
die gut waren und nicht so gut waren
aber jeder bericht glaube ich spricht
aus meinem blickwinkel nicht so prägnant
die dinge an von denen ich glaube dass
wir wissen dass es funktionieren oder
nicht funktionieren also da hätten sie
sich mehr gewünscht bleibt zu hoffen
dass man aus diesem bericht zumindest
lernt jetzt eher wie wir den herbst
angehen wir sind gespannt auf die
pressekonferenz stöhr vielen herzlichen
dank ihnen für ihre einschätzungen